let's let's get started so they're
heading i hope you've made already and
the date you can see there to explain
what these are i want to show you just
an example of what we mean by an
informal graph graph graph anyway
i have a friend who just a thirst rally
and he gets really upset when I say
graph we looked yesterday in a
particular kind of graph what was it
start with a tee a travel graph thank
you very much and on a travel graph we
noticed that what made it a travel
graphed was you've got these two axes
and they are time and distance very good
so when you've got time and time and
distance we call this a travel graph
because it shows how something travels
but of course we can have grass that
represent anything and I just want you
to have a quick look at this graph
whoops this is in the way and I want you
to see if you can work out with me
there's a there's some information here
that's helpful there's some information
appear that's distinctly less helpful I
wonder if you might be able to guess
that is there enough information that
you might be able to tell do you have a
suggestion so you've got four starters
these graphs are a bit weird they
clearly shows three different things but
the numbers you've got no you've got no
units you've got no description which
I've deliberately taken off spoilers
we'll see it in a second have a look at
the times have a good times and what's
happening there and notice that at a
certain time sort of it just kind of
well these things drop off anyone want
to have a suggestion I could give you
some clues but does anyone have a
thought what it might be what do you
think he's headed temperatures not a bad
guess temperatures not a bad guess
because this is as you can see sorry I'm
gonna keep moving sound wait or oh yeah
you can see this is an 8:00 a.m. to 8:00
a.m. this is how long a time period is
on this this
it's it's a day and a night it's 24
hours isn't it because it goes from 8
a.m. there's 8 p.m. in the middle
there's 12 all the way to announce this
is a 24-hour cycle so temperature bless
you is not a bad guess however I'm just
gonna suggest it'll be a weird place
that has a temperature graph like this
right going up and yeah it's like well
maybe this one but why would it go up
and down so why would fluctuate so
wildly so temperature is a good guess
but can we do any better
mmm look do you notice the blue and the
red graphs the blue and the red graphs
they have quite distinctive are bumps
did you see that and the distinctive
bumps there's three of them three and
they seem to happen at particular times
ma do you ever yes exercise related this
could potentially be a very fit person
I'm gonna say actually this graph
probably applies roughly to everyone in
the room very roughly just what do you
thinking so I think did you say you said
exercise heartrate they're pretty
closely connected I'm gonna say this
would actually even apply to someone
who's doing no exercise doesn't get
their heart pumping at all anyone want
to take another step I could give you
another clue there is something with
food is a really good guess because
let's have a look at those arm humps
right yeah this looks like nine o'clock
that hump what's this one here that's
around midday right oh yeah bit after
midday actually because this is this is
midday and then what's this one Sunday
this is a late dinner isn't it so you
have three humps that relate to when you
eat now that doesn't make these like
these are not fruit graphs you don't see
the food on there these shows something
changing as food changes
does anyone here are either themselves
or have a relative who's diabetic anyone
yeah
type 1 type 2 not sure okay add some
form of diabetes this is a graph that
someone with diabetes really has to pay
close attention to and then want to put
another guess in there now okay
sugar levels this one in here I think
yes I mmm no I think it's actually this
one in here what else could be on here
in addition to axis three graphs it's
not hot it's not exercise related at all
and does anyone know ah
say it again here insulin whose kind of
insulin yeah okay you can even tell me
what it does it has to do with
stabilizing well that's what's wrong way
has to do is stabilizing blood sugar
levels so you can see there's glucose
concentration so glucose being a sugar
of course and then what you've got here
in the plasma right here's insulin
concentration which are here in just
mention it stabilizes what's happening
here
and then there's an opposite to insulin
that's this I don't know if anyone's
heard of it glucagon right so these are
produced by the pancreas and they either
absorb glucose into cells or they
release based on whether you're reading
or not okay now what I want to point out
here is unlike the travel graph which
has distance in time you've got all
kinds of different things in fact look
more closely look at the units now
you've got units on there what units do
see milligrams is in here milligrams
what's this things I don't know what
that is nano grams right so this is very
very small quantities and we of course
have ml which stands for milliliters
what is this stand for have a guess
daiquiri it is this my guess is well I
didn't actually go and check but like if
milliliters is a one thousandth of a
liter then what would a deku deciliter
be it'll be a tenth I guess of a liter
so per 100 mils by the way that accounts
for why a microgram is much larger than
a nanogram right does that make sense so
they've chosen the appropriate scale I
think that one would be actual I'm not
sure what the U stands for someone can
look that up is that no no no but you
next to micro yeah I'm not I'm not sure
we should find that out anyhow what I'm
pointing out here is that we can have
graphs that represent anything okay so
when we have a look at this you've got a
really close attention to what each of
the axes are you often get these curvy
kinds of things which are quite
difficult to to sort of read but they
come from reality